[Applause]
[Music]
on November the 26th 2017 on Duras held
election some very peculiar elections
even though millions of people were
called upon to vote that day only one
vote really counted in the end and now
is the vote of the president Juan
hollando Hernandez who decided to stay
for another four years no matter what
the poll said oh yes here look at me yes
president Sanders very probably just
told himself well hey I like being
president a lot so why leave well since
then protests due to what has obviously
been a rigged election and assault on
democracy have occurred quite frequently
Honduras is a country that already
suffers from the tragic consequences of
a social and political model full of
corruption and violence a model dear
viewer that is so disastrous and
dysfunctional that it led Honduras to be
the poorest country in Latin America and
the third most dangerous country in the
world which isn't presently a war
[Music]
see on Duras is a small tropical country
with just over nine million inhabitants
located on a narrow strip of land that
separates the Caribbean Sea from the
Pacific Ocean indeed Honduras is one of
those places where we can find some of
the most incredible beaches in the world
white sandy crystal-clear waters and
lots and lots of coconut trees sounds
rather nice doesn't it
there's unfortunately drug trafficking
gangs and a political and economic
elites have prioritized above all
blundering the nation's resources they
have muddied and stains the reality of a
country that could otherwise be safe and
possibly even be considered a true
paradise here on earth some people don't
want to come here to claim bodies
because they don't want to be associated
with their family member who ends up
dead because here this gang members come
here to the medical examiner's office
and they case out families to figure out
who is next in that family unit that
they would be attacking
[Music]
let's hold on you might be thinking
right now I mean a small remote poor
country just another drop in the ocean
of problems right well wait a minute
because there's a lot more at work here
[Music]
what would you think if I told you that
we might be facing the first coup d'etat
supported by the Trump administration
well just check this out
[Music]
the fraud
on Sunday November the 26th 2017 general
elections were held in on Duras there
were two major contenders for the
presidency which is the most important
political position in the country on the
one hand we've got President Juan
Orlando Hernandez who was widely
supported by the country's economic
leadership and the international
community and he was aspiring to be
reelected a reelection by the way that
was very controversial because in
principle the country's Constitution
prevents it under Article 239 an article
that was declared in applicable in 2015
by a surprising and very controversial
decision from the Supreme Court now do
bear in mind here that the Supreme Court
is in actuality controlled by the
presidents so maybe that might have had
something to do with it just maybe
es que la corte Suprema de justicia en
la sala constitutional no esta facultad
apero declare our constitutional
lock-ins little show me this is what
article 239 says if a citizen has held
the ownership of the executive power he
or she cannot be the president or
designee article 239 of the Honduran
Constitution now on the other hand
Salvador Nasrallah are a popular
television presents that ran as a
candidate for the center-left parties
coalition the opposition alliance la voy
a quedar el thoroughly smoky skull
character Laura olviden se en este
momento los tiene trabajos el gobierno
si se console in un addicted ora C acaba
la empresa privada yo mas temprano Qatar
Des Peres / over an inclusive same
praises conmigo
lava-rock on a conserva wala factors but
in the initial votes count everything
pointed to Salvador Nasrallah's victory
see with almost 60% of the votes counted
he had a five point lead over the
president the advantage was so
overwhelming that the magistrates who
formed the Honduras Supreme Electoral
Tribunal qualified this lead as
irreversible and insurmountable however
suddenly the counting stopped there was
no additional information commuter
system simply collapsed New Balance
appeared and in the end several days
later the Electoral Tribunal awarded a
surprising victory to President Juan
Orlando Hernandez and Lovato's he
presented the electoral DC se cayó el
sistema como Carrillo con on daughters
to the money ravanamma Taliban there
were so many irregularities that the
Organization of American States itself
rejected the recounts and calls for new
elections el secretario general de la
organización de Estados Americanos Luis
Almagro public-owned surya sociales ella
o a proponent wave 'as elecciones para
guarantees arpa-e concordia en este pais
ante impossible idad de dar certeza a
resultados electoral is but that's not
all one day before the elections the
Economist published on its website
because it had a recording that proved
the government who is preparing to
distort the results of this election
so the big question now is well was the
election actually rigged now that is
hard to say for sure but let's just say
that the chances are really really high
all of this is without mentioning the
government's authoritarian behavior of
course what's the possibility of
electoral fraud was on the table the
opposition mobilized and organized
protest rallies they were peaceful of us
but the police didn't really seem to
care they still used as much force on
the protesters as they wanted
[Music]
[Applause]
for example on the evening of Wednesday
the 29th state forces fired tear gas at
a rally of about a thousand people who
were peacefully awaiting the results
indeed in this group that was even the
opposition leader
salvadore nasrallah the police they
didn't care there was a peaceful
demonstration or there were children and
elderly people present every time I
enter and enter animo Pueblo CO Colorado
Felicia Hamer me gusta esto tiene que
terminar esto lo tiene que saber todo el
mundo que hablan de una caja is the key
the government's even decreed a curfew
and since then rallies have been put
down with 30 people being killed and
more than 800 people being detained in
other words the evidence really does
point to a rigged election followed by
forceful repression all simply to
reinforce victory now having said that
we have several questions that need an
answer and clearly one of them is who
exactly is the president who is Juan
Orlando Hernandez the president while
there are two versions and they're
really different interpretations the
first is that of a leader with strong
hands but who can clearly rescue his
country from becoming a failed state the
second is that of an authoritarian
leader involved in corruption and crime
a leader who has taken control of the
country's institutions and who manages
them based on his own interests this is
something we saw in the case of the
Supreme Court and re-election over the
President as we will see in more detail
in a moment has the support of the
United States of America among others
and to be fair we must say that his
mandate has had many dark times but has
also had some good ones then let's start
with these good ones
[Music]
see when Quan Orlando Hernandez came to
power in 2013 on Durer's had the highest
homicide rate of a country that was not
at war every 13 hours a woman is
murdered in this country the number of
violent deaths of women in Honduras has
risen 260 percent it is true that
nowadays the country it still has a
serious problem it is still ranked the
third worst country when it comes to
homicides in relation to its population
and further there's the problem that
ninety percent of these crimes remain
unpunished
but things well I have improved in fact
this is the president's main pride and
joy with help from the United States the
government of Honduras has created a new
special police force which is financed
equipped and trained by the DEA and FBI
among others at the same time it has
expelled and replaced thousands of
corrupt agents it has dismantled several
drug cartels and extradited dozens of
drug traffickers to the United States it
even created parks throughout the
country which are guarded by the
military police so that children and
families can enjoy their leisure time
safely in this a lucha no eyewitnesses
know that emotional dance solo para
crafts ask the case device we went past
it interior or more north no medicine so
far so good right well unfortunately
dear viewer the story does not end there
with rainbows and butterflies
[Music]
there is clear evidence of the
president's corruption in fact the 2013
election campaign that brought him to
power was financed by money stolen from
the Honduran Institute of Social
Security and there are even well-founded
suspicions the president's Orlando has
connections with drug trafficking groups
the illegal drug trade in Honduras not
only infected much of its civil society
including the highest levels of
government and its financial sector but
also brought frightening levels of
violence to its people
June H Kim the Acting United States
attorney in Manhattan in any case
whether these accusations are true or
not repression deception and controlling
institutions can neither be justified
nor contribute to Honduras being able to
overcome the problems that impede its
development the president has clear
support from the international community
he has received money police Aid and
military and political support and the
truth is all the people they expected
something different but of course Divya
all of this isn't that strange in this
country
a cocktail of corruption and violence
Honduras is facing a difficult problem
there is a triangle of interrelated
powers that make being an optimist in
Honduras very very difficult political
power the economic oligarchy and drug
traffickers that's the most
representative case of all this is that
a Fabio Lobo he's the son of Porfirio
Lobo the former president of the
Republic who has just been sentenced in
the United States to 24 years in prison
for his involvement and activities as a
drug trafficker he actually did this
when his father was President of the
Republic and no we're not talking about
a rebellious son or anything like that
drug trafficking by the way is currently
the country's main economic activity
numero uno the near Puerto Verta call
trabajo de Mucha institutions
institutional Finland CNS another
example as the New York Times reported
is Parliament's it's an under equipped
building from the 1950s that lacks the
minimum necessary conditions which
contrasts with the deputies parking loss
a parking lot that is full of off-road
vehicles all the latest and most
expensive models and this affects
practically everyone both the government
and the opposition
the police and security forces aren't
removed from this either extortion and
bribery is common and it's widely known
that for these members have ties with
gangs and drug traffickers
Mara Salvatrucha gangsters in Rivera
Hernandez
say they receive warnings from the
police of impending sweeps and her
handed captured rivals to execute for
anything from four hundred and forty
dollars to two thousand two hundred
dollars ahead
Sonia Nazario Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist politicians security forces
gangs drug traffickers and lastly the
economic oligarchy ten families
controlled practically every economic
resource and have no problems paying
bribes and placing trustworthy people in
the powerful positions to generate
something that is not a market model but
a model that is entirely controlled by
the institutions well all of this makes
up a highly extractive resource network
and it's ultimately responsible for
Honduras not being that paradise that we
discussed at the beginning of the video
but we also mentioned the US government
specifically the Trump administration is
possibly being responsible for what
happened with Honduras elections so
let's get into that
[Music]
[Applause]
Washington's importance could be
forgiven for thinking initially that
Honduras is not that important to
Washington DC right well not exactly the
truth is that Honduras has a certain
importance to the United States for
three main reasons firstly because a lot
of the flight suspected of transporting
drugs from South America have to first
stop in this country secondly because
two years ago faced with country's
enormous crisis eighteen thousand
Honduran children traveled alone to the
United States border and nobody in
Washington really wants to see that
happen again and thirdly because
Honduras has traditionally been an
allied country in fact the United States
has had a military base there for
decades due to all of this the US has
spent billions of dollars in Honduras in
recent years to try and reverse the
country's problems while the Trump
administration it knows this and this is
why it supports Juan Orlando Hernandez
indeed this is what a prominent
Republican adviser said about the matter
Washington has invested significant
money in Central America to help turn
the security and economic situation
around
if Hernandez loses the election the
United States will have no effective
partners in the region the effectiveness
of our billions would be at risk and
more people might be tempted to come to
the United States
Daniel Varun day a Republican foreign
policy adviser and former official of
the George W Bush administration yes
Washington support is clear in fact the
police which were trained and financed
by the United States participated in the
post electoral events without any
complaints from the US Embassy
and this is because the US government
fears the ties that Salvador Nasrallah's
candidacy could have with the Cuban
regime and even the regime of Maduro in
Venezuela this is something by the way
that the candidate denies they are wrong
because my model is based in Uruguay or
Chile's moderate left or Costa Rica's
moderate right one thing is the
friendship that my ideological partner
Manuel Zelaya has with Maduro or Morales
and something very different is what I
think me who would be the president
Salvador Nasrallah anyway for everyone
watching this video from Honduras we
should state that things can change and
do tend to change there's the case of
Colombia as an example why now is your
turn do you think that we could possibly
be facing the first coup d'etat backed
by the Trump administration well leave
your answer in the comments below as
well as in this survey and I really hope
you enjoyed this video please hit that
like button if you did and do not forget
to subscribe to our channel for brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday
also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
but were not mine and as always thanks
for watching
the Catalina water table a pocket for
chaos in Quattro a new el dijo nadie
[Music]